with the power vested in me I now
pronounce you husband and wife you may
kiss your bride
I want to know what was it like that day
on set well gosh you want to talk about
beautiful set decoration they have gone
above and beyond for this wedding it's
really it's so beautiful it's so special
it's bringing the outdoors in a nature
white wintery springy wonderland I don't
even know if any of that made sense it's
just like a romantic explosion I mean
there's a tree in the saloon so they've
done an incredible job and I think you
know getting to see that that romance
slowly developed between Clara and Jesse
over the years it's just it feels really
good to get to take it to this next
level and show them entering the worlds
of husband and wife watching bill walk
Clara down the aisle hit me right in the
heart yes well first of all walk me
through that how emotional was that
scene for you it's really powerful and
then to walk her down the aisle and her
father was really it was so cool you
know it's really it was very real it was
really raw and it was also really loving
this was an emotional investment here
you know he was emotionally invested in
this as her Bob and he's never had that
moment before so it was beautiful what
were you feeling that day now a few
weddings on this show and you know I
feel like we've upped the ante every
single time and so this one was really
so spectacular but I have to give a huge
shout out to Aaron who was the visionary
behind the wedding look as soon as we
knew that a wedding was gonna happen we
she clocked it and she said um we're
gonna be filming this in November in
Vancouver we cannot do an outdoor
wedding which is how it was originally
written and and Aaron's like that
there's just no way like we can't have
the whole cast out there in wedding
outfits in November it's gonna be a
nightmare and so she started going on
Pinterest and finding all these
using indoor weddings where they
basically brought like a forest inside
and she started like pinning all this
stuff and sending it to our production
design team and they worked very closely
her with them and truly this one sets
the bar so high it's so beautiful like
when we walked into the saloon which is
where it is it's truly transformed it's
a different world it's a different it's
a whole different vibe a feeling it's
beautiful and I really hope it takes the
fans breath away ladies and gentlemen
may I present to you Clara and Jessi
Flynn gosh even born made the most
beautiful bride tell me I need to know
what your first reaction was when you
saw her wearing the wedding dress ready
to walk down the aisle oh I saw it a
little bit before that cuz I was I was
texting her like send me a photo I want
to see you from fittings just so
stunning just little the hair and makeup
team everything came together
she's obviously a very beautiful woman
already but putting her in all the gear
it was really it's very special and I
hope they're happy with the way it
turned out I think it's beautiful had
you seen her that day on set or was it
the first time you saw her when she
walked down the aisle no that was the
first time because that was my only
scene that day and I really wasn't
needed so that actually that time and
she's just evolved in general as an
actress her range she's just grown so
much and become more and more beautiful
every year and I think this really was
the pinnacle of something for her she
looked so beautiful she looks so
beautiful and she worked really closely
with our hair and makeup team to kind of
have a look that was authentic to Clara
but also
something special and unique for Clara
as well and she's got this really kind
of earthy but gorgeous classic look to
her Bridal look it was really special
because Jack was walking her down and
little baby Jack was in the front we're
trying to keep maybe baby Jack still
while we were shooting and he did really
good it was so poor just she's such a
great actor and such a beautiful woman
so to see them and it was really her
story like it was really about her
finding peace with her ex-husband and
you know I'm losing her husband so it's
a beautiful episode I look stunning
yeah yeah this really is a beautiful
ceremony I walked in tried to do
different things for all these weddings
that happen on the show over the years
and I think this one was the most
beautiful of them all they're trying to
go outside the box and the way they
decorated the saloon there was a lot of
fun the see her in the dress she's not
married in real life and she doesn't
have kids so I'm always honor about that
I'm like it's time times tickin thank
you for what for being here means
someone I can always depend on
I'll never forget this day
neither was there any behind-the-scenes
moments or things we didn't see on TV
you know is there anything you whispered
to her before that scene or anything
cutesy that you can share with us well
what's really great is what no one knows
is we're back there going are you gonna
start with your right foot or left let's
just let's just retract read a little
bit so we get those are the things you
actually talked about and then were you
act when you do it I like to stay quiet
I don't joke around too much when
they're emotional scenes I usually like
this for me to just stay in the moment
of my own self and then kind of connect
with the actor and so that's kind of how
it played out
I barred Eva from going into the saloon
at all in the days leading up to that
sounds intense but I just I wanted her
to be able to experience it once it was
all decorated and complete our set deck
team was working so hard to make it just
perfect Oh a really cool addition to the
set which you may or may not see I can't
remember if it's featured but there's a
large plank of wood plank this is a
larger one and all the ensemble members
took a moment to write a little message
to Jessie and Clara kind of like a
guestbook so it's a rustic organic
guestbook and kind of neat to get to go
through and read people's messages to
them thank you for everything
especially for making our day perfect
[Music]